that cracked you up judge the Biden
White House has a brand new enemy when
it comes to exposing the Border crisis
and yeah he's got better hair than Jesse
it's our very own bill malugin Politico
got the scoop that his reporting is
quote getting under the skin of White
House officials and leaving them
increasingly frustrated and why because
he's actually doing his job and reports
on the mess the administration caused
this is something we've been happy we've
seen happen every single day Del Rio
sector extremely hot averaging more than
700 apprehensions every day in the last
week this is the biggest single group
I've ever seen come up to the Border
they were opening this gate little by
little and then people would try to cram
through and come into the United States
border patrol doesn't have enough agents
to process these folks they're
completely overwhelmed
[Music]
deteriorating it's essentially a
free-for-all if people can get across
the river they can just walk in this was
a single massive group of about 167
people who crossed almost all of them
single adults hundreds upon hundreds
upon hundreds of these migrants crossing
the Rio Grande in broad daylight the
city of El Paso which is being inundated
by illegal Crossings right now
it's no wonder they're irritated if it
wasn't for malugent and Fox's excellent
border team no one in America would have
seen these images Biden's team would
rather everyone be in the dark about the
record-shattering two million migrant
Encounters this year so far but the
White House thinks this is all a very
new crisis
DHS put out a report laying out what
kind of a migration situation that we're
dealing with which is very new I
mentioned Venezuela I mentioned
Nicaragua I mentioned Cuba we have seen
an increase of about 121 percent from
since last year of what's going on with
these countries that are fleeing
communism so that has gone up and if you
look at North the North Central America
in the last three months we have seen a
decrease of about 43 so we are in a
different uh kind of migration
component right now
all right Jesse I want to talk about our
very own bill maluga not only does it
have better hair than you but it's his
own hair no Greg again that's slander
and I will be speaking to my lawyer the
political article said there is a Ducey
at the border I love how now a Ducey is
like lingo for a reporter that annoys
Democrats like oh see the guy in the
back Reuters he's a real Ducey and so
right so we have our own very stupid son
of a [ __ ] down at the border now too
which is great so the White House says
there's an alarmist quality to his
reporting
so Biden lets in a record amount of
illegals record amount of fentanyl
record amount of people on the terror
watch list but they're like don't be
alarmed by this the border is secure
they're not alarmed by any of that
they're alarmed that someone else's
alarm right so then they say they're
upset because our border Ducey uses
drones and they'd prefer that he uses a
tripod because the Drone takes too much
of a dramatic kind of footage now this
is the same political party that hired a
Hollywood producer to produce a mini
series about January 6 with crying uh
sound effects and about a thousand
different camera angles then they said
they're mad at are border juicy because
DeSantis leaked to him they told him
that he was going to do the flights to
Martha's Vineyard I mean at least
DeSantis tells them that he's doing this
Biden just flies them anywhere doesn't
tell anybody what he's doing he does it
in secret and then they complained about
the lack of nuance
they're saying that he focuses too much
on the number of the migrants and
instead of explaining the root causes of
the situation now I've heard the Border
Ducey explain the root causes and he
says The Rook causes are coming from the
White House they decimated all the Trump
border policies they'd stop building the
border wall and they've encouraged them
to come over and they're giving them
free bus passes and free plane tickets
the bottom line is this
there's only one reporter On the Border
yep
they don't want even one that's what
they don't want that's a great Point
although border do see just sounds like
something disgusting you find when
there's no bathroom around the judge you
know what's interesting he okay they're
calling him irritating but remember we
used to feel that Jim Acosta was
irritating but his irritating was
obnoxiously ideological where this is
just a guy who's just reporting on
things yeah all of a sudden the facts of
the truth are not what they're concerned
about they really think karees
Jean-Pierre says I don't know why we
would reach out to them they don't want
a solution they're putting people's
lives at risk so now she's talking about
people like Bill malusian he's not
looking for a solution he's just
reporting the facts well isn't that what
bill malusian is supposed to do and
what's amazing is when Kareem
Jean-Pierre she starts talking about the
fact that this is all new how is this
new that we've got this 18 months we've
been watching these individuals from
Cuba Nicaragua and Venezuela and you
know what's amazing thing today I think
was Ned price who was on the channel and
he was talking about all the successful
efforts they've made to try to resolve
the the crisis and he talks about the
summit that they had uh of the Western
Hemisphere this past summer to deal with
these issues and guess who wasn't
invited Cuba Nicaragua and Venezuela I
mean they don't even talk to them yeah
let alone try to figure out how to
resolve the issue and you know what they
want to put the burden on Bill malusion
to decide what are the root causes isn't
that supposed to be kamala's job he's
doing a better job than Kamala he is he
is he should be the vice president at
least he shows up every day yeah that's
true that's true and he doesn't have an
annoying laugh Harold uh it seems to me
that whenever a problem is Illustrated
it's either called a stunt or an
irritation what do you think
well I think everything that's been said
Is Right Here bill malusion should be
applauded for what he's doing you only
criticize and Dana has a much more
informed perspective on this but
politicians who criticize the Press
should only be critical it should say
there's only credibility behind the
criticism if you're saying you're not
telling the whole story there's a part
of the story I like for you guys to
uncover here's some additional
information there's no additional
information here we have a national
security crisis at our border I do wish
um that instead of directing anger at
reporters and every president has a
reporter or a couple of reporters they
don't like because oftentimes they're
asking questions that are irritating uh
and if you would just answer the
question maybe maybe the question would
indeed go away but we don't have a
policy at our border and we need one
it's a national security threat and we
ought to treat it as that I've said
before I believe we should build a wall
I believe we should invest in that
hemisphere I believe we should have a
streamlined Asylum process to make it
where everyone come in here doesn't
believe they're going to get in just
because they have a story that is
horrifying and gut wrenching we need to
have a transparent immigration system
that spells out for every migrant
immigrant that comes here how you
achieve legal citizenship think about
the people who waited five seven ten
fifteen years to get in the country did
it legally watching this it's an affront
to them it's a front and a front to the
country a front to our values and
there's no policy that anyone can
articulate please don't and don't
criticize Bill malusion get us a policy
at the border yeah it goes back to that
we we love uh immigrants coming here
because immigrants generally love the
country more in times but we also like
we don't like Line crossing you got to
wait in line we like Airlines too
apparently
um we were talking about this in the
break yesterday it sounds like it's too
unbelievable but we were talking about
how Venezuela was emptying their prisons
isn't this something that maybe our
government should be looking into yeah
don't you think you want to check that
out I guess they're busy going to the
school board meetings yeah but what's
the Nuance really like don't we have
some new ones so this is a wonderful
story it's my favorite story in addition
to the migrants theme because here's a
here's a little thing that happened last
night when the story broke in Playbook
political Playbook I sent it to Bill
illusion right away I said well well you
got under their skin and he said what's
Playbook which was the best answer he
could ever have given because he's so
not a DC guy he's a reporter doing his
job and you know along with Griff
Jenkins Casey Stiegel Matt Finn Alexis
McAdams amongst others all they're doing
is making the White House look like
Baghdad Bob they're out there saying the
birder is secure the border is secure
the border is secure in the meantime
it's like we're just showing you the
pictures every single morning hammer and
I laugh when you go to the reporter at
the border they'll say well Dana 200
migrants just walked across the border
20 migrants are lined up over here it's
unbelievable and they have the White
House has downplayed everything gas
prices
uh inflation pick up remember they got
mad at reporters for saying that
inflation might not be in uh transitory
crime Afghanistan baby formula and now
you have the border so I think it's also
pretty funny that the only reason the
media is covering the Border story today
is because it's because the White House
is mad at a fox reporter and they let it
out yeah it's my favorite story there
you go hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else